the changes in the structure of the
coronavirus genome don't have a
significant impact
they don't significantly affect the
antigenic structure
as the safety margin of covert 19
vaccine is quite high
therefore if the genome of the virus
changes the vaccine still remains
effective
according to research immunity from
coronavirus persists for six months
regardless of how it was obtained
therefore according to who
recommendations
for a more effective fight against
coronavirus everyone must be vaccinated
and re-vaccinated
due to new coronavirus strains the
clinical situation has also changed and
kovite 19 is also now dangerous for
young people
the clinical situation has become
heavier complications appear
shortness of breath occurs the lungs are
affected
and it progresses rapidly therefore
people over the age of 18 need to be
vaccinated
and re-vaccinated
due to the new coronavirus strains and
mutation we cannot judge the correct
number of antibodies to make people safe
from covid19
antibodies developed for the original
strain may not react properly to the new
strain
which is why it is so important to be
vaccinated this is a who recommendation
[Music]
indeed vaccines work we use them to
prevent infectious diseases
but there's no vaccine that can
guarantee 100 effectiveness
therefore there's still a chance that
those who are vaccinated can get sick
but vaccination helps to prevent the
development of severe forms and fatal
outcomes
vaccinated people have a risk of being
in contact with the kovit-19 carrier and
getting sick
therefore all those vaccinated should
follow covet 19 restrictions
such as wearing masks and keeping their
distance
you